before we dive into the session material
let's talk a bit about storing or
persisting data in Android first of all
why we bother to persist things at all
this is the era of the connected cloud
why don't we always fetch from there
it's really nice to not start the app
and see loading or even worse like this
a blank screen the faster people can use
an app the more it will be used
obviously if one has to select refresh
to get it to display anything that would
be particularly bad
another reason to persist our data is
that using any radio is detrimental to
the battery life of the device
especially the cellular radio many users
aren't on metered data plans or may be
roaming when they want to use your app
all those unnecessary data fetches can
add up there are still lots of places
that don't have a network connection
available one of the prime advantages of
having a mobile app is being resistant
to bad or non-existent Network
conditions after all you never know
where the user will want to use your app
as you might expect Android stores your
persistent data in the file system these
files can be stored in internal storage
that is private to your app they can
also be stored in shared or external
storage on older Android devices this
shared storage was actually on an
external memory card today most Android
devices only emulate this card so that
there is the shared external storage
apps need available on the device some
Android devices have emulated shared
storage and secondary external storage
Android 4.4 KitKat
added an API to allow developers to
access this secondary external storage
we're going to focus on internal storage
in this class check the instructor notes
to learn more about Android storage
locations as I mentioned before Android
persists data into the file system it
does provide two functional layers on
top of the file system in the form of
shared preferences and SQLite the shared
preferences class provides a general
framework that allows you to save and
retrieve persistent keys
pairs of primitive data types such as
boolean x' floats in Long's and strings
shared preferences is used by the
Android preference activity to store our
settings data such as the location Y
store things in an SQLite database after
all android supports both RAW files and
shared preferences for the same reason
that it's inefficient to find things if
you throw your clothes at a pile on the
floor storing things in an SQLite
database helps you organize and find
data easily thanks to the power of
indexing in tables an SQLite database
looks something like this fragment from
our weather database note that not all
fields are represented we can perform
queries using SQL against this database
such as the Select statement here which
returns the weather on the specified
date similar to what we'll want to do
for the detail view we can use a
slightly more complex query to return a
range of dates which is similar to what
we do on the main forecast ListView